[Music]
do
uh
good evening
welcome to the table
thrilled that you guys are all here
um i was thinking today is like today is
the very first day of may
like it just took me a second to kind of
realize that oh my gosh may is yeah may
is here
which means that if you've got kids that
school's about to wind down i don't
think that's a good good or bad thing
for some people summers are around the
corner
uh i started looking at the pool the
other day and i was like oh i can't wait
can't wait it's getting close too cold
right now but getting close so
but with that in mind since it is may we
do have a couple announcements
specifically for may uh since it is the
first sunday we are doing um our first
family
get-together dinner um that is going to
be over at hat creek that is in saxey
after the service so we hope that you
can join us there
also if you're interested we are having
um welcome to the table uh meeting
that's going to be on the uh
15th um thank you
that's right after the service as well
so if you're interested at all about
knowing about who we are you know what
we're about maybe place ways that you
can kind of get plugged in
um there's some cards when you exit that
door on a small little table you fill
that out and we would must only get in
touch with you and give you more details
about that as well
and then lastly
on
memorial day weekend because we're just
gonna have a break so no saturday sunday
service uh that particular sunday
evening so just kind of know
and plan that in your minds that we're
just never break for a firm service that
particular sunday
so with all of that
like i said it's may it just took me a
minute to kind of
get that in my mind for a while come to
that realization but with that being
said i will get started and
start starts off with the prayer
lord just thank you so much for
um this space
this opportunity this
place where we can come together
come and connect with each other
come and remember who you are
what you mean to us and just ways that
we can connect and just be here in the
moment and be very present
i pray that you just open our hearts and
our minds to what you have for us this
evening
in christ and i pray amen
thank
all right if you guys would stand up
with us
we're going to start out gary's going to
leave this first song it's called
springtime and one of my favorite things
about plants and
gardening and the spring is just the
sense of expectancy that we get when we
put something in the ground and you
don't have full control of it and that
is a great picture of life you know you
can do the work you can
get the soil ready you can do all your
things but in the end it requires some
trust right some open-handedness because
we just don't have as much control
sometimes we would like to
um so that's what this song is about
just us embracing the way that god comes
to us
and he makes things new and there is a
sense of um excitement with that there's
a sense of you know redemption in that
as we watch what was dead and follow
come back to life
and so um let's embrace that way that
god interacts with us as we worship
tonight
before we start i just want to say
i'm very grateful
for all of you are here today
it means a lot and i pray that god's
presence
[Music]
you're the resurrection
that we've waited for
you buried the night
and came with the mourning
you're the king of heaven
the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder the course
[Music]
we will sing a new song
reaching towards the light
your love is
[Music]
you're the living
waters for
[Music]
my soul
we will
[Music]
your love is like springtime
i will
[Music]
come to the soil
and like a garden i will
i will go
[Music]
reaching towards the light
to hallelujah
[Music]
like
are dismissed
[Music]
bring awareness
of jesus
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
thoughts
all your doubts became your god lay it
all down
lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all down
lay it all down lay it all down let it
all down they hold down at the feet of
jesus
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
memories we can't raise
lay it all down
we've come to fear we can't explain
there's nothing here that can ease the
[Music]
of jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down
all down lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
at the feet of jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay
[Music]
jesus
at the fear of jesus
[Music]
in that spirit let's go into our prayers
of the people and lift up the things
that we're carrying on our hearts
and you're welcome to join us online by
leaving
your what you're carrying tonight in the
comments
would you guys pray this with me out
loud
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so now we lift these
names and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
lord bless you
and keep you
make his face shine upon
be gracious
[Music]
um
make his face
shine upon
[Music]
sing amen
um
[Music]
and their children and their children
and their children these presents go
before you and behind you and beside you
all around you and within you he's with
you he's with you in the morning and the
evening and you're coming and you're
going and the weeping and rejoicing is
[Music]
he is for you
um
[Music]
your family and your children and their
children and their children may his
presence go before
[Music]
and within you he is with you he is with
you in the morning in the evening
and rejoicing he is for you he is for
you he is for you he is for you he is
for you he is for you he's for you
[Music]
is
god help us to remember that you
have come before us and you are beside
us and within us
all around us and you are for us
god help us to remember that you are on
the side of the widow and the orphan and
the oppressed it's not just a prayer
that we pray but it's a reality you are
a god that's on the side of the
brokenhearted you are with us on the
mountaintops and in our valleys
you are holding us when we are grieving
and you are celebrating with us when we
rejoice
[Music]
and god would you not be the only one
carrying us but would we carry you and
your presence
and your goodness and your life with us
into every situation into every
conversation
into every broken place in our life
and would we watch you do that thing
that you do where you bring things back
to life where you renew broken places
where you restore things that have been
lost
where you come and find things
that went away
god would we look to you and watch you
do a new thing among us
would we watch you care for us where we
need it most
[Music]
and then would we in turn care for
others the way that you have loved us
would we offer that to the world around
us
would your joy
and your healing saturate our lives
would your beauty
and your forgiveness
be the first thing that we give away
[Music]
would we be your hands and feet
and would we trust you
with our lives
they are yours
we are yours
thank you god
for being for us
we love you
it's in jesus name i pray all these
things and let's say together amen
thank you guys so much would you go
ahead and sit and as you do turn to
someone around you make them feel
welcomed and at home and then brett will
get us started on our message
[Music]
well good evening everyone and grace in
peace
it is so good to be with you so so good
um and i want to oh
i i want to extend that welcome as well
to those joining us on the line
um i was
checking folks online i saw mariah i
think earlier i saw ramon and miranda
delgado i saw eric nichols there's a
number of people so um and james
townsend's uh always there so
thank you we love you all lots and
anyone else who's on who's maybe
anonymous or hasn't commented or
something um
and i also want to welcome anyone here
who's new and just kind of you know
feeling feeling out the community thank
you for for being here
so um
we are in a series right now uh titled
uh first peter part three and uh you can
find parts one and two uh in the podcast
archives we've we've kind of wanted to
break this up we're basically just going
through the book of first peter um but i
didn't want to just do i don't know that
would be so many messages in a row on
first peter it's like 40 or something so
we're kind of breaking enough you know
we're just kind of doing five or six and
then hitting the pause button for a
while um
so kind of coming out of uh lint and
then easter sunday we're kind of coming
back to first peter so um
with that in mind the uh the title of my
message uh tonight is the simple gospel
the simple gospel and um our text is
gonna be just one verse
you're like man it really will take
forever to get through this whole book
i know
i know sorry i'm sorry i'll probably end
up doing the classic pasture thing which
is like you go so slow at the beginning
and then by the end you're just like
huge chunks just like half the chapter
we got to wrap this up so i don't know
maybe i'll do that but for now i'm being
patient so verse 18 uh it says this for
christ also suffered once for sins
the righteous for the unrighteous that
that word righteous is a kind of a one
it's one of those bible words you know
and it basically just means right
relationship with god's self others
the righteous of christ the righteous
one who died for us for the unrighteous
to bring you to god
he was put to death in the body but made
alive in
the spirit
so um
where i want to kind of start tonight is
talking um about that it was at that
opening line
for christ also suffered once for sins
and that word i want to talk about that
word that sins word i was thinking um my
opinion i could have titled the message
kind of like i did last week if you hear
last week you know the message title was
in all caps evangelism
we could have done something similar
sins you know just kind of like oh
okay
you know where is this going i think um
i think for
um for good reason you know we get a
little jumpy on it whenever the pastor
starts wanting to go he's gonna do a
whole sermon you know much less it was
like oh we got a new series tonight sins
you know it's like oh gosh here we go um
so i do i think we get a little jumpy at
times when pastors want to harp on sins
and um i think you know and for good
reason because at times like where it
can go not always but where it can go is
into a kind of like shame and
condemnation
game
you know where it's like you're almost
like weaponizing the sins and it's not
uh there's no sense of solidarity like
us together coming to god working
through things finding healing
you know it's it's no it's like you got
to get your act right you know so i
think you know for good reason we get a
little we get a little jumpy you know
around the sports in um
and uh
but here's kind of what's interesting
you know at the same time we're a little
bit nervous about it and we don't really
use it you know uh like even that word
you know we'll kind of find i don't know
other language other than like it just
sounds a little old-fashioned and clunky
and it's just been sort of abused and
you know we just shy away from it maybe
even we who kind of want to like maybe
jettison it entirely like you know what
we just need a new word that one's too
jacked up we gotta ditch it and move on
you know find something some way um
some different language to talk about
the same phenomena you know but we gotta
we gotta ditch it even we kind of wanna
do that um
it's interesting that we if you if you
look at like kind of what's going on in
a minute we'll give i'll give you
definition of it but
it's it's interesting that we who kind
of want to maybe ditch it at the same
time we are like more than a little
obsessed with it
and uh what i mean is
uh i've i'm always like watching the
social medias
and um
and i can just see how as really as a
culture because i mean certainly if it's
true in the church that we're like a
little jumpy around the word sins you
know i mean much less the broader
culture oh my gosh if you're like well i
just need to talk to you about your sin
you know oh my god oh no like that's
just a non-starter and that's well
that's an awkward thing to say
regardless but just even the language
you know it's just so clunky um and yet
we whether this in the church or outside
the church we here just are kind of like
i don't know about that at the same time
we're totally obsessed with it and i see
it um through especially twitter it
seems particularly kind of like
everyone's really worked up but um but
even other places facebook and
um
you can see people's obsession with both
um kind of systemic sins like the big
picture stuff you know government
um injustice or ecclesial kind of church
level injustice or just any sort of
institutional sin i mean
we're upset correct i mean am i like
overstating my point like oh yeah people
were like super hacked off there's more
colorful language i could use but we're
just we're real we're in all of our
fields you know what i mean like and
just to be clear i'm not mocking it like
for good reason it's jacked up the world
is ejected right so both at a big
picture systemic level institutional sin
and at a very micro level
i mean
we've all seen someone maybe we've been
that person if we got really worked up
who got kind of pulled off sides on
facebook and like airing our personal
grievances with so and so you know
you've seen these votes i know none of
you have ever done this but you know
it's like you'll never believe what my i
don't know fill in the blank my friend
my mother my who you know whoever
employer whatever and we just go off
and what are we what's the thing what
are we so worked out we're like i can't
believe they said that i can't believe
they treated me like that i can't like
what in what world is that okay
are you are you tracking like in that
moment what's what are we talking about
it's in
right like in essence
it's like it's super old-fashioned word
and yet
it's
that's it i mean we can call it
something different but in the end it's
like that's what the the bible is
calling
um sin here's i want to give you a
definition and i got this from uh kevin
garcia who some of you know from online
his youtube he is like mr personalities
he's great but um but he had this
working definition i think he might have
been quoting someone but sorry whoever
he was quoting i'll go with kevin garcia
he said this sin
is anything that breaks shalom
anything that breaks shalom and what's
shalom this is a hebrew word that it's
often translated into english as peace
but you know when we think peace we're
just kind of like i don't know a lack of
war
and that's shalom is much more than that
it's really about like the whole idea of
just human flourishing
you know it's kind of back to that word
righteousness like wherever there's just
when you know isn't it good like when
you're just in a good place with
yourself
like just good head space good heart
space
with yourself
with god
happy birthday to you
when people are celebrating your
birthday you know like it's just a good
day right and like there's something
about that moment where you're just in
tune with yourself with god with others
and it's like life is good that time
you're around a campfire roasting
marshmallows as you know as a friend
group or whatever like it's just that
like
shalom shalom
peace
wholeness
life
and so what sin
sin
is whatever
jacks that
up
whatever meant whatever kind of worms
its way into that and just starts
disrupting
and um
breaking
that's
that's a sin it's it's a disruption it's
a it's a breaking of shalom this is why
things like um racism
right it breaks shalom
um
addiction
breaks shalom
abuse
all the forms breaks shalom
lust breaks shalom hateful speech
breaks shalom
and
this is why those things are
sin
right
this is why there's sin there's um
a quote from a pastor and an author um
theologian named fleming rutledge who's
written a wonderful book on the the
cross of christ
it's a big book not for the faint of
heart but it's wonderful
and she this is a line or a few lines
from it
she said this
something is wrong
and must be put right
when we feel that in our bones
when we admit that something is wrong
not only with the whole human situation
in general
but also with oneself in particular
in that moment
god is at work doing what
bringing us drawing us closer to the
cross of christ
that's what it's about right in that
moment when we just feel i love how she
puts it when we feel it in our bones
that's a lot of what we see on social
media right people
at its best it's really people feeling
something in their bones and wanting to
name this should not be so
this should not be so the world should
not be like this
right can you feel in that moment like
that's what when you feel that
you're like you're tapping into the
heart of god who agrees
who very much is not saying oh no i mean
it's not so bad like no
no it is that bad it really is like the
world really is
it can it can be quite terrible i have a
friend and uh one of her lines and that
i love she says she goes she says
humans are the worst
and that's one of her lines and i always
love when she says it because it's just
it's one of those sort of blunt short
but so true you know like not to be
overly i mean obviously humans can be
beautiful too for sure
amazing
and at the same time
the worst
and when you feel that oh it's like in
that moment you're starting to
tap into something you're trying to tap
in really to the
story of the bible that's like this
process of trying to heal trying to
bring shalom
trying to bring shalom
um
i wonder
you know if this kind of that feeling in
our bones i wonder if this is one reason
that um the good news of jesus has
always been so resonant with um
the poor
uh
the marginalized
the
often the very old or the sick
those
who um like the addicted
it's often like through the message of
of the cross you know like something is
resonating
um
and and i wonder
i wonder if the reason why is because
when you're in the opposite place of all
those you know when it's like dude so
much money in the bank or
when we just feel i don't know like life
is good i'm feeling confident i got all
the community or just you know i feel
great you know whatever like the
opposite of all those things would be
like when we're in that place there's
just a sense of like
hey i kind of got it together and or if
i don't i know i'm just a few steps away
just a few tweaks you know i'll get it
like that's i remember thinking that
like in my early twenties like that's i
mean it's not i don't got all together
but i'm just a few tweaks away you know
uh oh naive brett
you never you never get it all together
do you
like you never arrive you never
but but when you're in that kind of the
opposite of all those other categories
it's easy to kind of tell yourself a
story about how like well don't don't
worry we kind of we kind of got it you
know um which then of course the cross
just doesn't make any sense it's just
kind of like that seems extreme you know
but
but when you've been the downtrodden
when you've been on the receiving end of
injustice
when you've been the one struggling
and getting lost in addiction
it's like you kind of have this sense of
like someone's got to save us
someone's got to save me
can you kind of are you tracking with me
um
i think this is one reason that there's
probably no
no more refreshing place to be in our
culture than an aaa meeting
because it's like finally
you're sitting in a little circle
with a group of people
and
pretty much i mean sometimes people come
there and kind of
you know him and haw and what but mostly
it's a it's a group of people who gather
together to say look
i'm done
pretending
and posturing and be guessing
i'm done
i'm here to be real
and honest
it's like that's so beautiful
and i think
it's in that moment
that it's it's a sort of a less poetic
way to say what fleming rutledge said
when we're done pretending and bsing
about the world or about ourselves
at that moment
we may not realize it but god is calling
us and drawing us towards the cross of
jesus christ
i remember i had a little convo um
maybe a few months ago probably good
five months ago with a friend jesse
watts
who sometimes plays guitar you know
might remember he's got the big old
beard
um and he's a good friend and i
remember i was in his office
and um just having one of those it was
just one of those honest conversations
you know where like
every person including pastor everyone
needs like at least a few people they
can like really talk with you know open
up with
stop the pretending and the bs scene you
know what i mean and so i was just
having one of those conversations like
with him
and um
and i was just opening up about you know
like
all the things you know so it's our
theme tonights and struggle
um i just opened it up and it was
interesting like i'm not necessarily one
of those people who just always like
feels god you know senses the holy
spirit in every moment i know some
people really have even here in our
community have like a very palpable
sense of the presence of god almost all
the time which is amazing beautiful
but i just don't i don't have that but
in that moment i'm sitting there sharing
you know just with him we're just
talking
and um
i just i don't know i just sensed
you know like god's presence
and
i was reflecting later about how um
jesus said right
where two or more are gathered in my
name
there am i in their midst
and i was thinking like
maybe maybe that two or more it's not
just people
who come together and say like you know
jesus or we are followers of christ you
know and then god's like oh okay well
now i'll show up you know
um
i i wonder if it's like anywhere
where people are done pretending and
bsing
and
are
sick of the world
their own struggles you know just all of
it and just a sense of like okay
let's just be real
let's just be honest i wonder
i mean anywhere people are being
vulnerable and raw
i i wonder um like if that's the place
where love
is actually happening
in thus
i mean where else would christ be the
god who is love like i mean
i don't know maybe i'm speculating but i
suspect that there's more truth in that
one than we realize
i think um kind of what i'm driving at
is um i really think the the gospel good
news of jesus really is like just this
simple and this beautiful when i was
lost
christ
met me in the depths
and found me
christ through the cross met me in the
depths i mean there's nothing more like
i mean the cross is such a symbol of
just the
worst
of humanity
didn't it i mean it's just the worst
like what sick minds
thought up that like
it's funny because we're so um used to
it now you know the
cross here back there you know we kind
of have them
and it's like we're i don't know if it's
shifted in our mind you know
what it means
and yet we forget like at its most
elemental level it's just the worst of
humanity and it's like in the cross
jesus just
just just bears it just
just takes it
in
and then
doesn't
reject us right this is this is where
often i think we get a little sideways
in the gospel we're thinking like i
don't know god was so upset that he you
know it's a weird non-trinitarian
understanding of of the cross basically
aguero god was so upset with us that
he's like son get on that cross you know
jesus is like no please not me he's like
i don't care you know like it's a weird
that's not a good understanding of the
cross
um instead it's god himself
bearing with us entering into our god
forsaken us and our struggles and our
shame and our addiction and our pain and
our torture and our crazy and our
he just bears it all bears it all takes
it on and then
transforms it in resurrection life like
it's really the cross is the place not
where we see the condemnation and
judgment of god upon all human you know
it's really the place where we see the
love of god
who says i love you this much like i'm
um
i'm dying for you it's first peter 3 18.
the righteous for the unrighteous
at second corinthians 5 21 he who knew
no sin
became
sin
romans 5 20 i love this verse but where
sin abounded this is the king james but
i wanted to use it because i just love
that word abounded what's abounded it's
like flourished
where sin just flourished
that's a good description of our world
isn't it like sin is just abounding
shalom not so much you know
we were struggling there but then i love
it we're sin and bounded
grace
god's grace
cross resurrection right grace did much
more abound
it's i mean it's just i just think the
gospel is just so it's so beautiful
so um kind of in closing i want to just
give you a few reflections like a few
kind of implications like okay so what
does this like actually mean from you
know my life um
let me give you a few first
um i don't save myself by trying real
hard
you know i know maybe that's too simple
but i think it's an obvious implication
where in the cross we see
this isn't going to be about us like
well don't worry don't worry don't worry
humanity we're like we're just a few
tweaks away from really getting it guys
don't worry about us we're
almost you know even like if you know
some of your history
at the turn of the uh
20th century coming into the 1900s there
was a lot of optimism in the world like
oh guys technology
science actually we'll get into this
message this will be the message next
week a little bit but it's you know this
idea of like oh y'all oh
good times they're coming it's gonna be
great and it's true at some level like
things did at one level improve or like
it has brought abundance and we have
less people in poverty and you know okay
that's true and at the same time then we
had world war one in world war ii
i realized oh gosh
like we're the well it's back to my
friend right we're the worst humans are
the worst crap
and so i think this is one implication
the gospel is like okay
it's gonna take us others
acknowledging oh god please help us
save us heal us
um
but the implication there is we're not
we're not just doing this ourselves you
know just
you know buckling those scraps and
trying hard um one way we might put it
is this the gospel of the cross of
christ crushes my own egoic need to be
my own savior
you know to kind of say i did this
that the cross kind of puts an end into
all of that um
the second second implication is the
church doesn't save people
that's kind of interesting thought isn't
it like i think um
and it's easy
well let me frame it like this like even
like pastor brett i i've never saved a
soul
the table's never saved a soul
like god uses people he works through us
but at the end of the day who's doing
all the heavy lifting here
god is
and and it really if you've been in the
church at all you you know that to be
the case you just know
because
well if you get to know me and anyone
else i mean you just know like oh these
are just human beings you know i mean
like
they try to be nice you know but at the
end of the day they're just human beings
and there really is something completely
miraculous about how people actually
change like i don't i think at the end
of the day we have we do all our things
right kind of the music and and and
meetups and you know the churches have
programs and you know various things
like we do all the stuff but at the end
of the day there is some miracle that
just has to take place like god
holy spirit please
do something
in our midst
change your hearts
another way we might put this is
the gospel of the cross of christ
crushes our own institutional egoic need
to be seen as the savior
you know we tend to think of like ego
the false self as just kind of like in a
person you know we each got our own
thing we struggle with but uh i mean
communities can
have a collective ego
can't don't they can't we
like that's a thing you know you start i
don't know and it's almost like hey yeah
maybe i'm not great but yeah we're
awesome you know it's like you get a
weird kind of
i don't know it's like a messianic kind
of
the church shall be your messiah you
know kind of further thing starting to
it's like it's never quite said overtly
just sort of shade into it you know we
just sort of slide into this idea of
like
okay we started with grace but really
we're kind of awesome
and
we're really doing a thing and you know
if you're not growing it's really just
your fault because like this is this is
a great thing you know um it's a weird
it's weird
um
the cross puts an end to that
it just said no no no no no no this is
about god
this is about god we come
to the photographs we meet christ and
we're like okay god do a miracle and the
church in you know here as community it
matters like us coming together and all
that but it's just it's a me it's what
the bible calls a um what theologians
call means of grace it's just a channel
of god it's like there's the riverbed
and there's the river
you know
where not the river
just the riverbed sort of this truck
some structure
and then
we just
trust for the miracle
um that's the second implication third
and finally there it means another
implication is that there is no all-star
team in the christian life
um i remember when i was a little kid
it's like 12 or 11.
and uh i was playing baseball and i got
selected for the all-star team
oh y'all i was so pumped
it was it's funny looking back on you
know we talked about ego and false i
mean i was like there was a little i
mean i wasn't like a total jerk about it
but oh i remember like putting on my my
hat alan all stars
oh my gosh i just wore that hat all
around town al i'm not just a little
leaguer i'm an all star now next year
didn't make it no matter let's just not
talk about that let's just think about
that first year um
and uh and what kind of what i've been
thinking about is how we kind of take
that idea of like the elite you know the
all-stars the i don't know whatever we
have all our terms for it
but um and we kind of bring that into
the church
you know and where we start to think
like well yes um
like
some people like there's ordinary folk
but then there's like the really
spiritual people
you know spiritual geniuses
they're like all stars
um again the cross to that says nope
we don't start as we don't start as
ulster no one starts as a spiritual
genius like nope we all start where like
in the common humanity like just us
together
there before
the cross
i mean i even think of
good friday services
sometimes certain traditions will have
people cry out crucify him
the community us all of us
spiritual all-stars i don't think i mean
what's that doing it's it's it's
communicating something right and not
again it's not about shame and
condemnation you're just terrible
there's nothing good all right that's
not i hope you don't hear me saying that
tonight i said it's just an it's just
honest and honest gut level kind of like
oh yeah humans can be the worst and uh i
like the apostle paul and i'm the the
leader
i can be the leader you know
at my worst
yeah there's no all-stars at the
beginning and not at the end because we
might say well i agree there's no
there's no we don't start with an
all-star but then team but then
eventually like you know some people get
there
some people arrive you know i don't know
pastors or the leaders the elder
leadership team or the uh i don't know
the deacons or the board or the monks or
the nuns or whoever you know um
but nope
nope
just uh i love how jesus even said um
we're just servants
that's the the greatest among you is the
servant of all
that was i think kind of foreshadowing
like that picture of the cross where the
cross community
so no
no all-stars
just um just us
just us
so um
i want to come back just um at the very
end verse 18 for christ suffered also
suffered once for sins the righteous for
the unrighteous to bring you to god
see that you isn't that's not written to
the all-stars that's like the you there
is plural communal
you us
to bring us to god we're all in need of
that so i don't know i i wonder if
there's anyone here who's ever felt i
don't know second rate
you know just like i'm just not cut out
for
you don't have the gifts
or the what i don't know whatever story
has been put in your mind like don't no
no no no no no we're all right there
we're all beginners
together
desperate for god to work am i gracie
does
he does
he does and he can work in you so as we
um
as we come to the table tonight
for communion
i want um i want to just be a moment
where
we're just re-centering on christ
we're just remembering again his broken
body symbolized in the bread his
bloodshed symbolizing the wine and it's
just a moment of saying
um
thank you god
thank you that
you died for me you saw me
um
and not just me but like the whole world
all of us you've met me and us in the
depths
and now you're inviting me to more
um so that's kind of the spirit in which
i'd like us to participate in communion
tonight so we practice what's called um
an open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
would like to participate you just come
forward i don't know if i have all my
theology worked out well if you would
like to
if you have enough faith where it's like
i want to connect with jesus
great then then you come forward and
participate
so let me invite you with this this
celtic christian invitation this is the
table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
in you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
[Music]
i wanna know you lord
like i know a friend
so i'm laying down
all my religion
[Music]
i'm laying down
i wanna know you lord
all my religion
i'm laying down
i wanna know
[Music]
i used to think
that i could box you in
but i'm laying down
i wanna know you lord
i used to think
that i could box you in
but i'm laying down
i wanna know you lord
i'm laying down
all my religion
i wanna know you lord
i'm laying down
all my religions
i want to know
[Music]
lord i have been told
to be ashamed
i don't measure up
lord i have been told
i'm not good enough
but you're here with me
i reach out and you
find me
in the
dust
you say no amount
can separate
us
[Music]
i reach out and you
find me
in the
dust
and you say no amount of untruths
can
separate us
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
in your
lord
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
in you lord
i reach out and you
find me
in the
you say no amount of untruths
can
separate us
will rejoice
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
in your lord
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
in you lord
[Music]
um
just as a couple reminders if um if
you're in need of prayer um tonight i'll
be standing in the back i'll be happy to
pray with you before you leave also if
you're visiting
and if you could
grab a card
there's also sitting in the back as you
walk out that door fill it out
as i mentioned before if you're
interested in the welcome to the table
class you can indicate that on the card
let us know we'll send you information
about that and everything um and then as
a reminder we are going to be having the
of our first family get together and at
yes at uh hat creek so join us there
after the service
um it also if you're just call the table
home and you're wanting to support this
ministry you can do that um by also
there's a box outside you can
give
a giving there or you go online and be
able to do that as well
uh if you wouldn't mind standing
i want to send you out with this
blessing
[Music]
so you
are a child of god
you
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go out in your week ahead with
it's yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you were
loved
you were worthy and you were accepted
just as you are
and go with
the god's holy spirit and desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with
thank you
[Music]
i will rejoice
in the simple gospel
[Music]
in your lord
i will rejoice
a simple gospel